là
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique
32 milliards d'euros et oui 32 milliards
c'est ce que coûte la formation
professionnelle chaque année en france
muriel pénicaud la ministre du travail a
présenté une réforme pour mieux utiliser
cet argent on va voir avec nos invités
ce que ça change pour les entreprises et
pour les salariés
quatre invités justement sur ce plateau
pour en débattre
tout d'abord océane charest goda elle
est vice-présidente socialiste du
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté elle a en charge la formation
professionnelle face à elle de nice au
maire député du doubs la république en
marche
phil et pio représente ici force
ouvrière fo
il travaille à l'usiné alstom d'ornans
et puis christine noël bouddha est ici
pour représenter le medef elle dirige
une entreprise de cartonnage d'une
quarantaine de personnes à baume les
dames un premier tour de table une
question puisqu'on va parler de la
formation professionnelle vos philippe
piot vous êtes entré ouvriers je crois à
alstom
voilà vous avez su suivi subi des
formations professionnelles au cours de
votre carrière
ah oui plusieurs oui oui tout le temps
il a eu plusieurs oui les étapes de
toute ma carrière
quarante ans skoula donc forcément j'ai
vu pas mal de choses oui on est obligé
de s'adapter on change de poste et il
faut effectivement avoir un soutien avec
la formation professionnelle de nice au
maire vous vous ai commencé comme
ouvrier aussi chez peugeot vous êtes
devenu prof de sciences éco et puis
après qu'est ce qui s'est passé aussi la
formation professionnelle tout le temps
la formation professionnelle a commencé
à 35 ans j'ai passé mon bac en bts et
plus que tout recours qu'ils ont permis
d'enseigner après les sciences
économiques suis vraiment un produit de
la formation professionnelle océane
shargh
donc vous vous êtes au départ
psychologue du travail
vous êtes jeune vous avez à peine plus
de 30 ans la formation professionnelle
ça vous cause ou pas moi je suis
effectivement psychologue du travail
donc j'ai suivi un cursus universitaire
que j'ai complété ensuite par des
formations dans le domaine de la
communication
notamment donc oui ça me parle alors
christine noël godin vous au départ vous
êtes comme denis sommaire un moment
donné dans sa vie vous êtes prof de
sciences éco votre mari dirige une
entreprise et puis d'un à cause de
problèmes de santé la plus pure et vous
vous avez pris les rênes de l'entreprise
alors formation professionnelle à ce
moment là ou pas comment ça s'est passé
le formation tout au long de la vie
jeudi et a géré le salon surtout
adaptation wii mais le fait d'avoir déjà
un diplôme de sciences éco ça aide quand
on veut diriger une entreprise ou pas
bien sûr que ça aide
dès qu'on a une formation générale de
base on peut je crois à s'adapter avec
un petit peu de bonne volonté un petit
peu de courage et puis et puis surtout
de la curiosité curiosité bien entendu
adaptabilité on en a parlé aussi avec
philippe piot nous passons à la première
partie de cette émission formation
professionnelle est ce que c'est un
constat d'échec
[Musique]
alors tout d'abord deux chiffres pour
planter le décor ici chez nous en
bourgogne franche comté on compte 21
opca alors on va pas trop vous abreuver
avec des sigles parce que la formation
professionnelle c'est épouvantable mais
un autre cas c'est un organisme
paritaire collecteur agréé c'est eux qui
sont chargés en fait de collecter
l'argent et puis on compte toujours dans
notre grande région 1330 organismes de
formation voilà donc 21 opca epu 1430
pardon 1430 organismes de formation
alors ce système de formation ça marche
ou ça marche pas qu'est-ce qui va qu'est
ce qui ne va pas on va te commencé avec
vous christine noël bouddha vous en tant
que chef d'entreprise est ce que vous
trouvez toujours du personnel formé
opérationnel j'aimerais bien vous
répondrais oui mais je suis obligé de
été choisi à la une on exactement il y
aurait pas eu des missions aujourd'hui
non vous trouvez plus est non les
métiers en tension pendant un certain
temps on a cru que c'était propre à
certaines branches ou à certaines
activités
aujourd'hui on sait que les métiers en
tension c'est absolument partout alors
océane donc charest goda la région est
responsable de la formation
professionnelle est ce que le fait de
vouloir faire une réforme ça veut dire
que les collègues ces collectivités là
ne font pas bien leur travail
moi je voudrais déjà permettez-moi déjà
des zooms et un petit peu et trois
choses déjà partager avec vous quelques
constats des objectifs et puis l'action
on va pas vous le dire qu'est ce qu'on
va essayer de quand même de parler tous
ensemble de cloud avait pas un traître
elle avait savoir vous faites votre job
vous ferait rapidement
c'est important de le dire parce que la
région fait son job comme vous dites
auprès des demandeurs d'emploi puisque
c'est tout le sait au coeur de l'action
politique menée par la région à travers
un service public régional de la
formation les femmes et les hommes
éloignés de l'emploi pas ou peu
qualifiés
d'ailleurs vous m'avez donné un chiffre
en 2016 que vous n'avez encore pas les
chiffres de 2010 est si je me trouve pas
ses trente deux mille personnes ont été
formées grâce au conseil régional
oui et même je peux vous donner là
aujourd'hui les chiffres depuis le début
du mandat
ce sont soixante mille personnes qui ont
pu être formées bénéficier d'une
formation
grâce en tout cas à au conseil régional
effectivement quand on a une région
comme la bourgogne franche comté avec
deux cent seize mille chômeurs c'est peu
c'est pas beaucoup c'est toujours trop
non non c'est pas ça mais le nombre de
personnes formées par rapport au nombre
de chômeurs est ce que vous aimeriez en
former davantage
bien sûr mais ça va être tout l'enjeu
d'ailleurs à travers le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
puisque la région bourgogne franche
comté va avoir va pouvoir bénéficier de
moyens complémentaires donc en plus déjà
des 130 millions d'euros que le conseil
régional investi dans les compétences
des femmes et des hommes sur le
territoire est bien en plus le
gouvernement met en place un plan
d'investissement dans les compétences de
plus 300 millions pour la bourgogne
franche comté est donc là c'est une
belle opportunité pour nous de
réinterroger aussi la manière dont on
forme les femmes et les hommes puisque
là aussi on n'est pas dans uniquement
formée plus mais formés mieux
philippe piot vous en tant que
syndicaliste quand vous constatez qu'il
n'ya pas adéquation entre les besoins
des entreprises et elle offre sur le
terrain vous en dites quoi a
effectivement un problème on constate
que par exemple dans la métallurgie on a
des emplois pour voir et on n'a pas les
salariés en face alors on s'organise par
branche
aujourd'hui c'est la branche qui gère la
partie formation et les entreprises donc
de la métallurgie et de la vie organise
des formations pour justement mettre d
en face des autres ce qui te vendent un
emploi et ceux qui cherchent des
salariés alors effectivement il ya un
problème déjà effet du casting national
où sont encore imprécises pas faire un
débat sur l'éducation n'est pas ce qu'on
va déborder dans le journal de 19h ce
soir oui mais la formation
professionnelle elle prend le relais de
l'éducation nationale une fois confort
ou de l'éducation nationale et c'est là
qu'il faut remettre les choses au delà
des cautions et redonner des formations
qui sont adaptés aux postes qui doivent
être tenus ce parce que vous aimez la
formation c'est crucial c'est utile
nécessaire obligatoires
sinon on n'y arrivera pas même celui qui
est qui a un emploi aujourd'hui il n'est
pas sûr de le garder il aura peut-être à
changer d'entreprise
il aura peut-être à changer de métier
parce que les métiers évoluent les
techniques évoluent donc forcément dans
une carrière on est amené à se former
c'est obligatoire alors démissionnaire
c'est déjà un constat d'échec quand on
est obligé quand on arrive au
gouvernement de réformer la formation
professionnelle c'est à dire ça marche
pas non non c'est pas un constat du
trial il ya le chiffre national 10 % des
demandeurs d'emploi accède à une
formation classée le chiffre national
mais quand on regarde ce qui se fait en
bourgogne franche comté par exemple la
bourgogne franche comté est une région
tout à fait exemplaire par rapport à
beaucoup d'autres affiches je signale
comme ceux qui ne suivent pas la
politique au jour le jour que denis
sommer non seulement est un député de la
république en marche mais qu'il a été
également vice président en charge de
l'économie au conseil régional de
franche-comté quoi je dis ça je sais
c'est pas moi qui était en charge de
cela c'était sylvie laroche maintenant
et pour ça que vous connaissez bien le
territoire national tout à fait mais
c'est vrai que la région bourgogne
franche comté s'est fortement mobilisée
dans le pré sans précédents plans
d'investissement lancés par le
gouvernement hollande il faut le il faut
le dire et cette mobilisation de la
région a permis d'avoir des résultats
tout à fait significatif
on est autour de 38000 demandé rappelant
qu'ils ont été formés l'année dernière
on doit être à peu près sûr ce chiffre
là c'est beaucoup plus que la plupart
des régions froid là et c'est dire
l'importance du plan d'investissement
qui va s et 15 milliards au niveau
national qui vont être qu'ils vont être
mobilisés avec beaucoup d'argent aussi
pour la région bourgogne franche comté
donc il faut poursuivre dans cette
dynamique là pourquoi parce que celles
et ceux qui sont formés les demandeurs
d'emploi dans les six mois
57% environ 60% des gens qui sont formés
trouve un boulot dans la magie en givre
bourgogne franche comté sur 100 chômeurs
qui suivent une formation 55 retrouver
un emploi dans les mêmes fins voila
voila mais c'est bien faire dans les six
mois vous dire que là la formation
professionnelle c'est aussi de la
remobilisation au delà de la
qualification des gens de l'accession à
d'autres de nouvelles compos
c'est de l'art mobilisation donc c'est
eux marchaient bien fait fermer deux
figures permettez moi aussi de compléter
vous l'avez très bien illustré madame
août bodin tout à l'heure par rapport
aux besoins des entreprises
aujourd'hui on parle d'une reprise
effectivement c'est un bel héritage du
quinquennat précédent si je puis me
permettre
effectivement il ya une reprise il ya
des entreprises des entreprises qui ne
qui ont du mal à recruter aujourd'hui
avoir les besoins en compétences
nécessaires mais aussi je pense que cela
aussi c'est important parce que ça
impacte toutes la manière dont on forme
aussi les femmes et les hommes à savoir
que vous souhaitez vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure et très justement vous voulez
des gens avec bonne volonté qui est des
gens qui ont la motivation qui puisse
s'adapter
qu'ils soient curieux aussi autonomie on
l'entend souvent
or ça ce sont des compétences on va dire
plus transversale de l'ordre du savoir
être qui ne s'acquiert pas en situation
de formation théorique on va dire à 6 8
heures derrière un bureau donc là aussi
et c'est pour ça que je parle et
d'opportunités pour réinterroger innover
dans la manière de former aussi merci
madame
on va passer donc maintenant à la
deuxième partie de ces émissions la
réforme et ses changements très attendu
[Musique]
alors muriel pénicaud la ministre du
travail a présenté sa réforme de la
formation professionnelle la semaine
dernière et puis mercredi le président
de la république
emmanuel macron a fait un déplacement à
tours pour en parler
on écoute le changement principal pour
les salariés c'est que leurs comptes
formation ne sera plus créditée en heure
comme aujourd'hui mais en euros 500
euros par an ces sommes seront
cumulables hauteur de 5000 euros au fil
des années pour les salariés non
qualifiés le crédit sera porté à 800
euros avec un plafond à 8000 euros
les sommes épargnées serviront à
financer un stage de formation ou à
acquérir un diplôme et seront à l'avenir
collectées par les urssaf une agence de
la formation professionnelle sera créé
c'est une refonte en profondeur du
système de formation français
ces 15 milliards d'euros
d'investissements sur l'apprentissage la
formation des chômeurs la formation tout
au long de la vie 15 milliards d'euros
c'est un investissement inédit il
passera par les partenaires que sont les
régions par pôle emploi par l'ensemble
des acteurs qui seront labellisés par le
gouvernement parce qu'on veut derrière
qu'il y ait des formations suffisamment
longue pour qu'elle va permette
d'accéder à des vrais métiers et pas des
formations cache sexe en quelque sorte
en forme des gens déjà bien formées pour
dire qu'on a formé quelqu'un et où
derrière on évalue la qualité de la
formation et ses débouchés
alors mesdames bodin vous en pensez quoi
de cette réforme
les mauvaises langues jeunes ou des
langues tout court disent que le medef a
tenu un peu la plume de madame pénicaud
oh je ne pense pas qu'elle avait besoin
du medef pour tenir sa plume c'est pas
vrai mais globalement on peut dire que
de mendes est plutôt satisfait que
les besoins des entreprises soit
davantage prise en compte et que
l'apprentissage aussi qui est un dossier
qu'on soutient depuis très très
longtemps depuis très longtemps on nous
dit que nos pays voisins comme les
suisses où les allemands par exemple
utilisent l'apprentissage pour avoir de
meilleurs résultats
donc je crois que là on vient de faire
un petit peu la synthèse de de cette
réforme
alors pourquoi synthèse parce que on
parle évidemment vous l'avez rappelé
alain godard 2,7 ce plan
d'investissements d'avenir mais il faut
aussi mettre un petit peu en regard ce à
quoi va servir ce plan d'investissements
d'avenir c'est pas pour rien que on va
transférer entre guillemets la mesure
aux urssaf le soin de collecter à fond
c'est bien évidemment parce que pour
l'emploi a besoin de s'occuper du
million de chômeurs qui est qu on sait
qui est concerné en tout cas en projet
sur ce plan et puis également tous les
jeunes éloignés de l'emploi qui eux
aussi sont concernés massivement mais au
delà des syndicalistes j'aimerais bien
qu'au niveau du patronat on dit aussi
que dans nos entreprises
on a aussi besoin de formation mais de
formation pour les actifs et pour
l'apprentissage qui est aussi même
un de nos chevaux de bataille
important là et puis vous dites aussi
que il faut former aussi pour
l'excellence et plus et pas que des
portions sans vérification repris un
petit peu fait monsieur kiosque on sait
quoi par exemple par exemple le compte
de formation le compte personnel de
formation qui passe d'heure en euros
avec au minimum 500 euros 800 pour ceux
qui n'ont pas ou peu de qualification
vous en dites quoi vous concrètement bas
j'ai l'impression que ça va quand même
limiter les droits avant 17 heures en
heures effectivement on avait 20 heures
24 heures avec les différents
dispositifs qu'on a pu connaître par le
passé et que le dif est cette fois on va
avoir en euros 500 euros c'est rien du
tout où vient d'avoir une présentation
du plan de formation chez nous à alstom
une heure c'est 50 euros ou quelque 500
euros vous avez 10 heures et à 10 heures
qu'est ce que vous voulez être formés
donc sérieusement si on veut vraiment
une formation qui permettent d'accéder à
un emploi ou à changer d'emploi
il faut effectivement beaucoup plus
d'heures que ça on va faire répondre
tout de suite les députés de la
république en marche
500 euros voire 800 pour les moins
formés ça représente pas grand chose
vous en dites quoi
je dis que c'est simplement un minimum
et que les accords d'entreprise vous
permettre de dabondy de ses 500 euros
c'est ça la réalité c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas fixé un plafond s'est fixé à un
plancher
on a fixé un plancher ça peut pas être
en dessous ça veut dire que les
partenaires sociaux peuvent abonder très
largement
c'est une question que du mot essentiel
66% des cadres dans les entreprises
accèdent à une formation 30 % des
ouvriers
moi c'est ça la réalité les attaques et
qu'est ce que la lave réforme va changer
on voit bien que votre public cible
c'est quand même les gens peu ou pas
formés mais en quoi cette réforme de
muriel pénicaud va aller dans ce sens là
on remet au coeur du débat la question
de la formation professionnelle je finis
ce que je disais tout à l'heure
50 % des emplois vont évoluer
considérablement dans les dix ans qui
viennent
10% des emplois ne sont pas encore ne
sont pas encore des métiers connu ça
veut dire que si on veut que les
salariés dans les entreprises qui sont
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises
puissent accéder à ces nouveaux emplois
il faut absolument qu'il se forme et
donc le premier objectif de cette
réforme c'est vraiment de remettre au
coeur du débat entre les partenaires
sociaux la question de la formation
professionnelle est absolument essentiel
à la fois pour le plein emploi mais
aussi pour la promotion sociale pour
permettre à celles et ceux qui
travaillent de continuer à avoir un
emploi et pour ça ce pouvoir construire
leur avenir
point de vigilance par rapport à cette
réforme le premier c'est ce qu'on
pressent c'est quand même une forme de
road de recentralisation c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya des annonces
philosophiquement on peut partager
on voit des choses de qui vont de
l'ordre de la simplification
effectivement dans cet univers la
formation professionnelle complexes etc
et même carrément taxé d' usine à gaz
par beaucoup
ses voeux l'envié points et la doutre le
2e finit juste sur ce premier point
parce qu'effectivement dans l'airé par
nom par rapport aux réformes aujourd'hui
on n'a pas la déclinaison la déclinaison
sur les territoires première chose dont
points de vigilance
deuxième chose sur le cpf congés
personnels de formation de personnel de
formation vigilance aussi pour que les
individus et les personnes les plus
qualifiées les plus à même d'utiliser
leurs comptes personnels de formation
l'outil puisque ce sera à travers une
application
voilà la formation ce sera des
matérialiser comme moi là et
effectivement les personnes
on va dire à l'aise avec l'outil
numérique eux plutôt qualifiés ayant de
l'appétence haussier par rapport au
sujet de la formation auront pourront
s'en servir en revanche les personnes
les plus éloignées de des sujets de
formation ne manipulons pas forcément
l'outil numérique parfaitement en tout
cas on voit la qualification aussi pour
ces c public justement comme ça va être
des méta réalisé qu'il fallait sur
internet durant une application et c'est
justement les gens non qualifiés peut
qualifier c'est votre cible et ces gens
là est ce qu'ils auront un
accompagnement les gens peu qualifiés
ils ont pour nom bien sûr ça va être la
jungle quand on mène on citera pas
l'être dès qu'il ya quelque chose de
nouveau voilà tout le monde tout le
monde s'affole
en réalité le numérique c'est
aujourd'hui notre quotidien et il ya
énormément de choses que les que les
ouvriers dans les usines
voilà font avec leur art est
d'accompagner y aurait un appel
demandant va utiliser facilement en fait
il y aura une corrosion pardon il y aura
une convention avec les régions pour une
application la réforme dans les régions
c'est à dire une contractualisation avec
les régions c'est absolument essentiel
parce que les régions reste un
partenaire il y aura un appel d'offres
pour qu'il y ait un opérateur dans
chacune des régions qu'ils puissent
recevoir les appels renseigner au niveau
régional pour console humant récurrence
ustr mais je n'ai justement de tout à
l'heure donc madame boutin disais donc
formé à l'inter des entreprises et que
on est des niveaux d'excellence vous la
région
viser surtout donc les publics qui sont
en difficulté qui n'ont pas ou peu de
qualification peu de qualifications
c'est un c ap est-ce que là vous n'êtes
pas en opposition on voit bien vous le
disiez tout à l'heure les 32 milliards
investis effectivement sur le domaine de
la formation ce sont des sommes
considérables
on voit bien aujourd'hui la formation
bénéficie aux plus qualifiés or on sait
que plus - les gens sont qualifiés plus
ils vont vers du chômage ces accords
avec eux mais et au jour que tout le
monde en bénéficie et pas que un public
de favori aujourd'hui au conseil
régional effectivement notre notre
action elle vise les publics pas ou peu
qualifiés éloignés de l'emploi donc pas
de public oublié et pas territoires
oubliés parce que la question des
territoires elle est éminemment
importante
aujourd'hui on parle de formation on
parle d'entreprises qui ont des besoins
sur les territoires avec des femmes et
des hommes qui recherchent plutôt en
proximité un emploi ou une formation
donc la notion des territoires elle est
capitale marie-guite dufay la présidente
de région a mis en place d'ailleurs des
rencontres d'affaires économie emploi
formation pour pouvoir toucher tous les
territoires et enfin donc pas de public
oubliez pas territoires oubliés pas de
secteurs structurants pour la région
oubliée aussi et donc une formation
adaptée aussi aux différents secteurs
structurants l'agriculture ces
conditions
la franche comté est une région qui est
riche de ses petites et moyennes
entreprises un peu partout sur le
territoire donc je pense que quand on
vous parle de territoire ça résonne bien
évidemment bien évidemment et puis la
réforme territoriale avec avec la loi
d'autres a de toute façon remis en jeu
le dire en lumière tous les territoires
de façon à ce que personne ne soit
laissé pour compte bien au contraire il
me semble qu'on qu'on est en train de
faire un faux débat
ce qui est important en france et que
les entreprises trouvent tout quelles
que soient effectivement leur lieu
géographique mais aussi quelles que
soient leurs besoins que ce soit
effectivement des ouvriers par exemple
n'oubliez pas que
à l'horizon 2020 c'est à dire dans deux
ans il y aura un tiers des actifs qui
dans notre région franche-comté vont
partir en retraite
ceci sur cette dernière décennie donc je
crois qu'il y avait en 2010 à peu près
un million deux cent mille actis il y en
aura plus de 300 milles qui seront
partis en retraite sur ces décennies à
horizon deux ans maintenant
donc il est bien évident qu'il faut
aussi penser que la formation
professionnelle va pouvoir apporter un
plus aussi bien aux entreprises qui vont
devoir recruter deux nouveaux salariés
et également à tous ces demandeurs
d'emploi chômeurs qui eux aussi peuvent
se positionner
parce qu on attend que dans nos
entreprises et c'est là aussi où il faut
peut-être qu'on n'en trouvera entre
guillemets le débat sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
oui mais là aussi la farine à vadim tous
les jours validerait c'est en lisant
tout va débrancher la finale de 19
heures de demain je suis d'accord il
faut libérer pillot vous quand on dit
ouvriers cadres est pour vous personne
ne doit être oublié ni les uns ni les
autres vous voyez ça vous dans votre
quotidien
bien sûr alors après là il ya deux
débats quand on est déjà dans
l'entreprise et que le métier évolue
elle a effectivement il faut que les
gens puissent se former à leurs
nouvelles fonctions
et puis à ce qu'on pas de travail alors
là il faut les mettre en face d'un
emploi et là c'est une autre une autre
démarche menée on s est compliquée et
d'aujourd'hui en plus avec la précarité
du travail
on forme plus de mécaniciens nous quand
on a besoin de quelqu'un de notre
entreprise
on va la boutique d'intérim et qu'est-ce
qu'on prend des bouchers des charcutiers
enfin voilà qui sont pas formés il faut
qu'on les forme ocean ou métier parce
que forcément il ya un écart substantiel
en khl ajustement entre vous qui êtes
ancien excusez moi et puis vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que ça fait 40 ans que
vous êtes en entreprise entre les
anciens qui ont de l'expérience et les
jeunes qui arrivent
diplômé par exemple ça se passe comment
pour la formation c'est ça sa frite au
face à ça frotte un peu entre les deux
il ya plusieurs niveaux et al tutorat
donc et l'accompagnement de ce qui
arrive ça c'est une première chose et ça
fait aussi partie des participations
bien sûr et puis après il ya ce qui
arrive avec des diplômes mais qui ne
sont pas valorisées puisque c'est pas ça
correspond pas et du coup ils vont
arriver à prendre la place des autres et
là il peut avoir des petits flottements
ah oui très sérieuse bowie et donc on
arrive aujourd'hui avec des personnes
surdiplômés qui vont prendre des places
éventuelle de ce qui aurait dû
progresser et on arrive à des situations
un peu conflictuelle mais bon là c'est
dans tous les métiers je pense à il n'y
a pas que dans la métallurgie ou le
rencontrent fréquemment oui juste en
oublie ce qui reste moins de trois
minutes
est ce que le budget formation dans une
entreprise qui va pas très bien ce n'est
déjà pas le premier qu'on supprime on
qu'on rabote au je ne crois pas au
contraire garder pendant la crise de
2008 il ya eu énormément d'entreprises
qui justement été en difficulté qui en
ont profité pour faire de la formation
et pour pouvoir conserver et gradés si
je puis dire le niveau de leurs salariés
ces défis sont formés au mieux il est au
contraire l'opportunité d'avoir de
meilleures compétences en interne
donc je pense que non non là y'a pas du
tout de déphasage viennent à daytona ya
monsieur qui vous l'avez avec thomert en
sucre activités en forme le plus
personne et oui on à plescop il tente
alors c'est le moment on respire un
petit peu il faut on va peut-être pas
souhaité une crise quand même on va voir
le taux de formes et de salariés de
demandeurs d'emploi et je pense que le
marché du travail aujourd'hui les
fragmenter on parle de reprise on
s'aperçoit qui est quand même
aujourd'hui parmi les offres qui
apparaissent sont loin de 10 % de cdi
donc ça veut dire qu'on est
essentiellement sur des cdd des contrats
d'intérim et voilà et c'est le marché du
travail aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs depuis
plusieurs années maintenant
donc comment la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on accompagne comme on
sécurise les parcours effectivement des
salariés et donc ça réinterroge
effectivement la notion de formation
vis-à-vis des métiers of en plus à des
compétences cas des métiers messieurs
vous voulez
prévoir pour pouvoir finir cet
investissement la forme c'est bien sûr
faux il faut essayer de garder parce que
c'est pourri tout dépenser alors il
reste une minute on va finir avec le
député de la république en marche si ça
vous dérange pas donc madame boudin ya
fait allusion tout à l'heure j'ai
l'impression que cette histoire de
l'emploi c'est marche sans jeu de mots
sur trois pieds
la formation professionnelle dont on
vient de parler l'apprentissage dont
madame bodha a parlé et puis également
la réforme de l'assurance chômage
vous n'allez l'impression que là vous
êtes en train de donner un grand coup de
balai ce qui est sûr c'est que on est
confronté à des enjeux qui sont tout à
fait considérable la question du plein
emploi est l'objectif de l'âme de la
majorité je veux pas faire injure aux
autres
c'était aussi pour l'ancienne majorité
un objectif essentiel et on sait que les
dispositifs que nous avons en place ne
sais tu ne sont pas satisfaisants et
donc il ya besoin de réformer mais
j'aurais juste rajouter un petit point
moi je crois que je crois beaucoup ou
campus de formation tout au long de la
vie c'est à dire qui s'appuie notamment
sur les lycées professionnels
on a parlé proximité tout à l'heure
parce que les lycées professionnels s'il
accueille à la fois de la formation
initiale des apprentis des personnes en
reconversion professionnelle des
demandeurs d'emploi eh bien on va se
voir aussi maintenir des formations ce
sera le besoin de la fin merci merci
beaucoup merci mesdames merci messieurs
merci de votre attention et puis bon
dimanche à tous au revoir
[Musique]